il y a à peu près un an le communes 19
apparaissait dans nos vies des cas
signalés à roanne puis un confinement de
cette ville chinoise jusqu'à la mise
sous cloche de l'activité humaine
presque partout sur la planète
en un an on compte plus d'un million et
demi de morts et plus de 68 millions de
cas mais un an après une question
essentielle reste sans réponse
d'où vient le virus sascoc d'eux mêmes
aura-t-on un jour la réponse à cette
question
[Musique]
le premier patient atteint du communes
19 a été déclarée par les autorités
chinoises le 1er décembre est
paradoxalement depuis on n'a pas
beaucoup avancé
il crée des hypothèses certaines sont
plus solides que d'autres ont enregistré
1 priori aucune à la fois la fuite de
laboratoire qui est pas la plus quoi
mais qui peut pas être rejeté
aujourd'hui comme celle d'un autre
intermédiaire qui quelqu'un d'hypothèses
plus chante les reste à savoir quels
autres ce que l'on sait c'est que ce
coronavirus le sascoc 2 est très proche
d'un autre virus présent chez les
chauves-souris et raté g13
il est similaire mais pas assez pour que
ce virus ait pu passer directement de
cet animal à l'humain il a donc eu
besoin d'une espèce haute pour que le
virus puisse s'y développer avant
d'atterrir chez les hommes et très vite
on a accusé le pangolin d'être cette
haute parce que l'animal est très prisé
en chine pour ces soi-disantes vertus
aphrodisiaques et aussi parce qu'on a
découvert chez lui un couronna virus
similaire sauf que depuis la théorie du
pangolin commode est remise en question
déjà le cours n'a virus présent chez le
pangolin et bien m'en proche du
start&stop deux qu'on le pensait
initialement
deuxième raison le pangolin est un
animal solitaire et pour qu'un virus se
développe il faut que lot et beaucoup
d'interactions c'est pas parce qu'on va
côtoyer d'une chauve-souris qui porte
lui
raté g13 qu'on va choper le sarcopte il
faut qu'ils aient un contexte
particulier pour favoriser sa
transmission et il faut qu'il y ait une
mutation qui permettent au virus de
s'acclimater à sion alors si ce n'est
pas le pangolin quel peut être l'effet
est ce qui fait le lien entre la
chauve-souris et l'humain est bien pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien certains
chercheurs pointent du doigt les
élevages présent en chine puisque en
2003 le tarse cauvin était apparu dans
un élevage de style est le problème
c'est qu'au milieu de cette recherche
scientifique qui se mêlent la diplomatie
et on peut pas dire que la chine coopère
efficacement aujourd'hui le régime
chinois dans son de célébrer cette
victoire entre ville et bien sûr on n'a
pas du tout envie de me laisser passer
sous silence ces faux pas initiaux parce
que si l' oms l'organisation mondiale de
la santé a affirmé qu'elle ferait tout
pour connaître l'origine du virus
d'habitude nous abriter et canberra
times m solutions to find your ride
elle n'a toujours pas pu sont sur place
pour enquête l'oms voudrait l'haouran et
pouvoir faire une enquête de première
main aujourd'hui les chinois pour le
mans résiste à cette demande et donc il
ya des officiels et chic qui sont venus
à pékin ont négocié mais non pas puisque
d'accord ce sont les chinois laisse
entendre au milieu qui accepteraient de
en gros de données les données aux
officiers des semis ne laisseront pas
enquêter librement
d'autant que sur place la propagande du
pouvoir marche à plein régime on laisse
répondre cette idée que le virus ne
vient pas forcément de chine que
l'épidémie a certes été détectée
auch in one mais que ça peut pas du tout
dire que ce virus est d'origine chinoise
donc on a lancé une contre offensive
diplomatique face aux accusations qui
avaient été proférées notamment par les
états unis un homme qui parle chinois
une autre zone d'ombré persistent sur
l'origine du sart skov de selon une
étude en italie des patients avaient des
anticorps contre le covin 19 dès le mois
de septembre 2010 soit bien avant les
premiers cas déclarés alors comment
l'expliquer on démarre pas une pandémie
avec un ce virus il faut qu'ils aient
plusieurs feuillets la meilleure
métaphore c'est celle de l' incendie un
giga incendie qui démarrerait pas avec
eux un seul foyer avec plusieurs petits
foyers en a qui font long feu qui
disparaissent et y en a un qui vient se
comprendre pour plein de raisons
différentes
un contexte favorable ces véhicules
épidémie c'est pareil il est très
probable que le virus circule et déjà
auparavant
d'autant que les symptômes du commun 19
ont pu se mélanger à ceux d'une grippe
classique ou d'une pneumonie une chose
est sûre c'est que c'est bien en chine
que tous les ingrédients sont réunis
pour créer une pandémie mondiale et la
question est de savoir si on saura
vraiment un jour ce qu'il fait parce le
problème c'est dieu dans le contexte
actuel
pas seulement du coït en avant le
contexte de régime du mené par le parti
communiste la chine
j bill qui contrôle le plus en plus
d'informations sur les chercheurs
solomun diversiterre sur les officiels
de toute façon c c'est quasi mission
impossible d'obtenir ces informations là
[Musique]